the onetime A Perfect Blend of patience
power and precision tonight that's all on
display in the NHL one-timer competition our
Allstars will take three one-timers from each
of three designated areas and points will be
awarded based on where the hug enters the net
sneaking in upstairs get four points score
into those two triangles earn three points
or put it right down the middle and get two
if a pu ricochets off one of the dividers
they'll tally one point but if the shot hits
the bottom barrier a post or the crossbar or
misses the net entirely they get nothing each
player gets one minute to fire all nine shots
if a pass is not to their liking they can let
it go but can only get five total passes at
each location and if a stick breaks the clock
will stop most points win the challenge let it
rip yes passers for this event
the first overall pick pick of
the 2023 NHL entry draft number 98
for the Chicago Blackhawks Conor
Berard and playing in his six NHL allstar game
the captain of the Pittsburgh Penguins Sydney
Crosby [Applause] so it's the one-time competition
these are the players who chose to participate
in this again these players will pick four of the
first six competitions M I think the one-time goal
is the most exciting offensive play in hockey
it's explosive it happens out of nowhere and
these dudes can all bring it they can all really
shoot the puck there I I look at uh David poso
and Austin Matthews as being the two favorites in
this uh competition they're all great obviously
but those two to me are natural goal scorers and
we've seen it all year the way they can score in
many different ways but their one-timers are
some of the best May probably the two best in
the league and as you saw introduced Sydney Crosby
will be one passer he's left-handed and Conor Bard
being right-handed will be a right-handed passer
so Elias Patterson can really bring it so it's
you're looking for obviously to score and there's
different score totals depending where you put it
player taking three one timers from each spot on
the ice top of the circle now at the dot that's
a post that zero point then he'll move to the
bottom of the circle a maximum of five passes
you can take a pitch you're allowed to take a
pitch like in the Home Run Derby and you can
see Pon not really taking a full Slap Shot he's
more almost like a almost a snap shot but uh very
little back swing and that's prob for accuracy
for more accuracy exactly so 20 points for pet
and again this is not so much we the
hardest shot competition later that's
more about obviously miles per hour this is
about accuracy in point total just shooting
off the pass it doesn't have to have a big
wind up in order to get it off and this is
to your point this is all about the accuracy
and getting into the top portion of net to
collect as many points as you can so Pon going
first he's now on the lead so as you can see
our live standings he's projected with five
points now those aren't truly earned until
the competition is done but McDavid got those
five in the fastest getter McDavid not in the
one-timers pon poock Miller Matthews McKinnon
coocher off dry settle barzel so Bard passes
to the righties Crosby passes to the lefties
so it's Bard to Nathan McKinnon well McKinnon
I'm sure is going to have a little bit of
bigger wind up there and uh not so much
actually they're kind of slow passes here
to help them gather and snap and go for a
obviously a pass with a little less Pace on is
much easier to time and get good good uh your
good Glade on or good wooden weed to say in
the old days but you can see mcken there very
accurate yeah that top blue bar is what you're
looking for and you can see he has picking it
off picking it off didn't like that one again
you can take a pass it's really important for
the passer to make sure that puck is coming to
play you can see it rolling a little bit which
makes it a little bit hard but [Applause]
that's so he takes the lead with 23 points
Bard and McKinnon don't for these players are
looking for that top shelf all the time cuz
they know they got to shoot it over the goalie
stick so when they're practicing this onetime
you know obviously in their practices they're
going for that underneath that crossbar all the
time so Sydney Crosby Returns the pass to the
left-handed Leon dry Sidle hard to Discount
Leon dry Sidle when I pick Matthews and pasut
cuz this is one of the best ones with with
mcdavis feeding in the passes all year long
but we'll see how he does he's got one of the
biggest blades in the in the league great shot
there these guys will be Olympic teammates with
that great announcement today M at the NHL going
back to the Olympics in 26 and 30 and Conor Bard
and Nathan McKinnon could be line mates one
day you asking every one of those players do
they want to play in Olympics they'll say yes so
I'm glad they agreed that they're going to send
the players and it's a great opportunity for
every one of them Leon drad he's probably the
king as you mentioned of the power play one-time
getting passes from McDavid mostly so 23 points
from McKinnon the score to beat yeah he gets
passes from McDavid all year long and always
gets passes from Crosby in this all sort of game
that's pretty cool not too bad huh he only goes
top shelf when he's at the bar look at the big
long stick he has there he's got a good angle
in this sure enough that's pretty good so 22
points for dry Sidle that puts him in front
of Pon but behind McKinnon yeah McKinnon was
eating up that top shelf and that's where the
points are going to be made if you can get it
up there you also risk going over the net but
[Music] unbelievable Tru from that [Music]
angle looks easy watching it at home BCI
but when you get down on the ice with
the everybody watching the nerves are
there it's not as easy as it looks what a
year for Nikita COV being Lefty once again
he'll take the passes from Crosby one of my
favorite players in National Hockey League
to watch his offensive acum in is incredible
that's what we want back scratchers that's a
true onetime yeah he's not letting it oh
there he goes he I think that's what the
NHL envisioned with this it's really they
didn't expect a onetime to be a bunch of
snapshots two-pointer there got
to get those blue ribbons that's
what McKinnon did so well a career
year for Nikita coer off 32 goals
53 assists 85 points in 49 games
he'll take that pass from Crosby
oh Coo's got to pick it up
here y so a disappointing 17
for Nikita kucherov oh looks like it's going to be
19 so McKinnon holds on to his lead he's
gun him for that Five Points that's what
happened there he hit that crossbar top there
didn't get anything out of it that's right
cross barss are zero that was unfortunate so
you see the shooters who remain as McKinnon
looks on if there's a tie then they'll split
the points so there'll be four and A2 and 4
and A2 if someone happens to tie mckinon at 23
JT Miller what a year he's having in Vancouver
the conu just got Elias lyol PK suban sit on
the point he's their team to come out of the
west of course the West is loaded that was
a massive pick up for Vancouver LOL was a
tremendous hockey player plays a 200 foot gain
complain in any situation good in PH good in the
power play now they got a right hand strive on
that power play already that's thr Dynamic JT
Miller born in East Palestine Ohio he could be
a little bit of a sleeper in this competition
W there's a four- pointer Miss from top of the
circle yeah he's shooting with a lot of velocity
too very accurate shooter always with a high
shooting percentage doesn't have to have volume
to get his goals well he's a big strong kid and
I'll tell you what he's got a lot of skill that
it's on displ the last couple years in Vancouver
and I got to know him a little bit when he was
with the Rangers good kid plays hard plays with a
lot of [Applause] power so JT Miller with 18 yeah
he missed a net a couple on the high they cost
you he doesn't doesn't do that in the game no he
doesn't and now you hear the crowd come to their
feet the greatest goal scorer currently on the
planet is a kid from Scottdale Arizona on Pace
for 70 goals this year amazing and it wouldn't
surprise me if he does it to do it but the power
and the skill that he plays with is unmatch in
the National AR league and he is definitely the
league best goal scorer right now 26 years old
grew up in the desert went to a Phoenix Coyotes
game and saw Alex gokin score that amazing goal
on former colleague Brian bue and he was hooked I
want to play hockey dad and here he is now amazing
Sacrifice by his mom and dad in order to get him
to where he needed to go to play and look at the
results that we're seeing now 40 goals already
this year again on Pace for 70 he needs some
blue ribbons to start dancing here in Toronto
to match his sweater went over and gave Sydney
Crosby a high five before the competition began
yeah looks like he's going to fall a little short
absolutely there is a time limit but
when the NHL kind of went through there
experiments no one really came close
enough just goes to show you what I
know they're all good my favorite
isn't currently in last place he
is our Emily Kaplan part of our coverage she's
down on the ice with Tom Wilson Emily Tom you
got to be a spectator tonight what are you looking
forward to most uh it's it's great hanging with
the guys uh we got a front row seat here so uh it
seems like a really fun event and just hanging out
with the guys have a couple beers we got the
night off so watch the guys go to to toe who
do you think is going to win this all I honestly
I was talking to a few people about that there's
so many so many great players out there it's uh
I don't know we might have to take a couple side
Wagers here and take a horse but I think Conor's
probably the favorite but there could be some
sleepers well if you wanted to give $1 million
to one of these guys who would you give it to
if I wanted to give a million doar to someone
o I don't know that's a tough one I guess Nate
maybe cuz he picked me last night in the draft
so we'll go with that awesome thanks Tom enjoy
your few beers thanks a lot I think he's already
had a couple uh barzel out there now from Conor
Bard righty to righty not coming in mess
that Matthew would be one of these guys
who would really want to try to win this
title oh I think every one of them wants
to win obviously but being at home in front
of his home fans and all that look at this is
a lofty title to be named the NHL's most
skilled player there's not player in the
league that wouldn't want that title just 13
goals for Matthew this year those Islander
fans are always screaming shoot when he has
the puck he loves to set up his teammates and
that camera man almost took that one off the
teeth right there he better get out of that
corner I think he took it off the ankle ouch
so Matthew barzel 16 points one better than
Austin Matthews keeps Austin in the seller and to
your point even if you don't win these events you
still get points by being in second and third
there so every shot counts got to hit the net
though so our final participant is going to be
David poo 61 goals last year 33 goals this year
a one-time machine on the Bruins power play got
11 Power Play Goals this year so he knows what
he must do 23 points to get the full Five Points
oh that hits the post shot number one two points
there you go there's the one he needed he'll
take his time I think this is smart you can
see the the timing he has on his shots not only
velocity but just perfect perfect positioning
adjust to the puck there so when it's coming to
him he's hitting right between his legs big four
pointer there he's got a chance three more pucks
he can take it hard to get get it up from this
angle yeah 18 he's got a shot mess that's 21 here
he knows he needs this one he got [Applause] it
24 he gets McKinnon by a point well I was I was
B 500 one for two David poo one of the League's
best Shooters shows off his skill right there we
have breaking news they took two points away from
David past knock maybe they just got the wrong
point total by sight and upon further review
it belongs to Nathan McKinnon now pasta still gets
three and a half because he was tied with dry cdal
so there's the current standings two events down
four to go will eliminate two after six events